辺り一面全部雪
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです。
まあ富山にかえっt...
太陽まぶしぃ....（そりゃそうだろ）
まあ富山に帰ってきたわけだが、
とりあえず今日は、
ゆきだるまを作りたいと思います
眩しいな、ほんと
なぜ今更雪だるまを作るかというと、
雪に触れる機会がすごい久しぶりなので
純粋に
作りたいんや（確信）
純粋にゆきだるまを作りたいっていうのもあるんですけども
この23歳というこの成人男性
になった年において、
小学校の時によく
雪だるま作ってたんですけども、
あの頃は響きだった。
筋肉もここ（頭）も全然空っぽで
効率の悪い雪だるまの作り方を
してたのかなと思いまして、
今！
最高の筋力！
最高の知性！
全てを兼ねそろえた今の私は！
最強の、
なんか
引くくらい
みなさんが引くくらい
大きな雪だるまを作れるのかな？
と思って
今回作ってみようと思った所存でございます。
僕
明日静岡帰るんですよ....
最後の思い出にさ、
デケェゆりっ...ケュッ
デケェ
雪だるま..
作ろうや！（せやな）
やっぱ、雪って明るいなぁー
雪明るくて全然見えない画面が。
はい。という訳でまず、
雪を触ったことのない人のために
雪だるまの簡単な作り方
を教えてあげます。
まず適当に.....
あっすげぇ今日いいわ。
雪の質にもよるんですよ。
サラサラのゆきとか固まりにくいんですけど、
今回すごい固まりやすい
雪のタイミングです。これはいいぞぉー
ちょっと小さめの雪玉を作って
これを後、コロコロ転がす
だけでどんどん大きくなっていきます。
塊魂です。
ポイッ！
転がしていくと分かるかな？
周りの雪がくっついてって
明らかに大きくなってくんですよ
いやもうヤバイもうヤバイ
あもうヤバイもうヤバイや
ほんの30秒転がしただけで
あの大きさだよ！
うわぁぁああヤバイヤバイ
30秒転がしただけで
この大きさまで変わり果てます。
あーー↓
今筋力がまだあるので
もうちょっと大きくできると思います。
じゃ回していくよ
雪だるま作ってます。
うわぁあああ！！
すまんみんな
これが限界や
転がすのはやめます（はじめん、えらい）
転がすのは重過ぎてもうできないので
手でちょっとずつ
こうやって
大きくしていきます。
ではいきましょう
ここらへんの地元の高校生が
居たんですけど、
シャベルを貸してくれるみたいで、
ちょっとシャベルでやります
もう無理だ！
日が暮れてしまう！
マジで。
結構高くて
ここら辺まで
来てるんですよ。
もう一歩です！多分...
もう無理！
OK。
はい！これで
下半身は完成です！
えっ。でもデカイよね？
腰ぐらいまであるんで
かなり大きいほうだと思います。
はい。というわけで
雪だるまの
下は完成したんですけども、
日が暮れてきて
時間がないので
速攻で頭だけ作っちゃいます。
うわぁぁぁああああ！
せーの。
OK！
OK！OKOK
いやまだです。
ここから上を、
もうちょっと大きくしていきます。
こわーい
怖い？
妖怪
妖怪か。
はい。というわけで、
完成しましたー！
身長だけでいうと
ほぼ僕と一緒ですよ。
うわぁ！
180ぐらいか
180cmぐらいでございます。
はい。というわけで
一人で作ろうと思ったんですけど、
地元の男の子
が手伝ってくれまして、
無事完成しました（グロ注意）
なんかトミックさんぽいな...（トミックさん、すまない……）
というわけで
私の作った雪だるま
とくとご堪能あれ！
なんという事でしょう。
ただの雪も
匠の手にかかれば
あっという間に
顎の魔神
になってしまいました
美しい顎のりんかく
2つの触覚が特徴的な
とっても可愛らしい
雪だるまの完成です
あぁ！（きもすぎる……）